y'all listen listen up
hey
look look look
how do you feel now that this whole
ordeal is basically over
how did you feel afterwards tell us
really and truly i felt like
this time but i still yeah i still you
know was like
whoa but i'm telling you when i woke up
this morning
i'm like it can breathe
man listen it's like
i see it all over your
okay so let's talk about dr obang he is
a miracle worker he is everything you
i'm telling you
how did it feel to put your hands
through your hair man
it's like it look it's not that much no
more
but it's like man i thanked him and
hugged them and think them
like i just come from appointment a
little while ago and we took so many
more pictures
and i think then and i hugged them and i
hugged them and i think
i like yeah yeah i didn't even know what
else
you know what could i do for you you
know let me know right
and another somebody else asked me was
like when you got
off the plane did you know
that he was going to take this over here
i told him when i got
on the plane i knew he was going to
if he's going gonna come get me from
violet
to bring me to beverly hills he has to
know something
so he flew you out yes wow
we're still here right now i'm still
here wow
yeah i have to go get another treatment
today and i'll get another one tomorrow
and then he's sending me home with some
stuff so what are the treatments for now
some type of my scalp okay it has some
damage on my scalp and around the uh
around the edges but i mean i still have
hair
he's hoping the treatment you know keep
it from you know the little parts
falling out
but i could i could put your hands
through it
yeah i could yeah
oh my goodness was the procedure painful
did you
see that part i don't know he told me he
didn't have to put me
into the deep sleep okay but from the
video that i've seen
i heard myself talking i have no clue
what happened when this was going on
there i have no clue so if it hurts
all i remember getting up and he said
give us some more give us some so
so how long did he say it was going to
take for it to heal
he told me don't put nothing on it for
six weeks he said i can um
put on a wig but as far as putting
anything on my scalp six weeks
beyonce is he's coming to new orleans
he's gonna eat some crawfish with me
yeah we're gonna um get away together
so i'm so happy for you i'm
telling you i'm telling you
have you even thought about as far as
what you are going to do with your hair
after these six weeks are up or are you
just
no i'm not um i'm not going to relax
anymore i'm not doing that
i'm just going all the way natural yes
girl
i'm going oh look team natural again
your natural beauty i love it
in the back with my sister um hey cut
the ponytail
that part is rather than curled up not
in the front it's still spiky
yeah but yeah i'm just gonna get all
that um trim
so girl you can have a nice a bomb
nice short cut something not listen i'm
never gonna lie to you i'm gonna rock
the shortcut for these six weeks
but i'm gonna pop that wig yeah i need
to
you like hair i love hair you said that
you said i love you
all right well now that all of this is
over what's next
like as far as the gofundme i am going
to buy me a wig
a wig out of them and
i'm gonna pick three families out of st
pineal parish
to help out because again we never
thought for one second
that this was gonna be the way it is now
and people
are like still going off on me that is
still up i just told my little sister
we have to take this down and we have to
take it down no
like whatever's in there this is what
i'm gonna do with it
when i you know get back home because
again i pretty much love everybody
how to think when i perish and majority
majority of them love me too yeah so i
mean i don't even know who to pick
but i'm gonna pick three people three
points
three families yes yes because again i
never thought for one second
it was going to be that much because at
this point i think it's like 20 000
wow yeah it's just
you know sometimes we never know why
things happen
and of course i feel like of course
mistakes are sometimes our biggest
lessons as well but on top of that
i feel like it has really shown us the
people for one
that will knock somebody when they're
down and for two
it's also shown us that the world is
full of people with big hearts
my inbox is still full of people
from all around the world offering up
ways to help you
like it's something it is something and
i know people are saying this is dumb
and we shouldn't give it attention but i
do think that there's something everyone
can take from it
and that's when someone's down show
kindness show grace
and i said that don't don't kick me when
i'm down because again
when i got up the next morning after i
made that video
i didn't think for one second my baby's
gonna be like mom this is the main views
even after she said that i still didn't
think
like i would be here or talking to you
or
i i didn't think it was going to ever
ever go you know
this far like but it's the reason why it
did
and that's what i'm saying instead of
looking at the negative parts and
nitpicking
look at the good that came from it do
you feel like you're going to take a
break from social media
for a while after this i told i saw him
i told him i was deleting everything but
he kept saying don't delete it
just don't get on it yeah yeah i said i
was deleting
everything because i mean you know i
could go i get in the shower
you know put my head back i was thinking
i could
listen listen i don't y'all don't know
like what's going on
you know i feel it i feel it through the
screen
you look you have me smiling ears
because i want you to sit back relax
enjoy yourself you've been through some
things
but you have a message that you just
want to share for those who
you weren't able to get to in your inbox
or just say thank you for sending love
and support you have a message you want
to share
i'm coming to everybody individually and
i will thank
everybody before i log off this girl i'm
gonna need you to get my password and
thank the people in my inbox because i
was like do i respond what do i do
i'm thinking everybody everybody over
this weekend i'm dedicating myself to
thinking everybody now all the
hatred stuff guess what i'ma thank them
too
i'm thinking everybody because i'm good
yeah i help you i'm saying i'm good
i am good so you know whatever it didn't
kill me all i did was
you know making sure i'm good